foreign
[Music]
Downing Street the home and headquarters
of the government to find out more about
this trusts and the issues she has to
deal with
[Music]
and standby for never seen before ocean
hi I'm Lucy hi I'm Sheena and join us on
FYI to dive into the unexplored ocean
[Music]
hi there it's been a time we will never
forget where the whole country almost
Stood Still to remember our Queen
tens of millions of us in the UK tuned
in to watch the state funeral and many
of you even managed to join the crowds
in London and Windsor some of you have
contacted the FYI team with your
thoughts on the day we will never forget
watching the Queen's funeral well I felt
obviously a sadness but mixed with the
same surprise a pride to be among the
many thousands watching with me from
Hyde Park
the part that definitely struck me the
most were the hymns for the entire park
stood up and was facing gratitude to her
majesty the Queen the most emotional
part of the funeral was when the corgis
came for a last minute goodbye
I think this definitely does feel like
the end of an era because there will not
be any Queen for a while if I got one
final message to the queen I would say
thank you for all your commitment to
this country and the Commonwealth your
lifelong service of care and humility
for all of us
[Music]
the royal family continued to mourn in
private we won't see much of them for a
while
but for all of us it's a time of massive
change we now have a new head of state
King Charles III and of course a new
prime minister Liz truss as life returns
to normal Liz trusts is under pressure
to deal with some massive problems for
the country so Braden headed to Downing
Street to find out more
hey Braden so you made it to Downing
Street then what have you found out
about our new prime minister hey Maya
it's do you write her name is Liz truss
and she used to be in charge of
international Affairs but now she's in
charge of the country and she's moved
into the government HQ the home of the
government number 10 Downing Street
which is right there and she has some
urgent things to take care of right yeah
so she's got two main issues that she
has to deal with number one being the
rising cost of things like food and
energy and the other one being the war
in Ukraine I've put together a little
report to explain it all here it is
Les trust got the most votes from
members of the roofing conservative
party to replace Boris Johnson he
resigned in July when a growing number
of conservative politicians criticized
his leadership and behavior during the
pandemic so here's what I found out
about Liz Tross she was the foreign
secretary the government minister in
charge of the UK's relationship with
other countries and she does change her
mind a bit
this party unlike labor will not duck
and weave from debating the issues
people are interested in she started her
political career in a different party
the liberal Democrats and then switched
over to the conservatives
she supported the campaign for the UK to
stay in the European Union but then
supported brexit after a majority of the
public voted to leave
well let's hope she doesn't change her
mind about being the Prime Minister
she's got some really big issues to deal
with right here in the UK
urgently the price for just about
everything he saw in at the moment from
food and clothes to petrol electricity
and gas that's because they're all in
short supply the covert pandemic meant
that many things were not made for a
long time and the war in Ukraine has
also led to a shortage of food
ingredients we get from the country
Russia which invaded Ukraine is also
making it difficult for many countries
to get a hold of gas and oil leading to
sky-high energy bills
[Music]
since she's been back to work the Prime
Minister has been in face-to-face talks
with world leaders including President
Biden the talks are focused on the war
in Ukraine
in recent days the Ukrainian Army has
taken back control of a huge area of the
country from invading Russian troops
mistress is also hoping world leaders
can work together to bring down the cost
of things meanwhile she has announced
the limit on how much all families and
businesses in the UK can be charged for
gas and electricity and plans to help
our parents keep more of the money they
earn
[Music]
so while the conservative party was
focused on electing a new prime minister
and a new leader for many weeks very
little was done to help struggling
families less trust though was promised
to get us through these tough times and
I've got hold of some FYI viewers to get
their opinion
hi guys hi
hello so what do you make of the new
prime minister I'm really glad that Liz
truss is the prime minister now that she
is focusing on the cost of living crisis
I struggle to agree with the points that
Kai made her response to the cost of
living crisis has seemed to be to
decrease taxes for the wealthy while
leaving the poorest in our society in
the exact same position and that doesn't
seem like really the way to go right now
I'm not sure how much I trust her yet
but I think time is up so what do you
want from the new prime minister one
thing that I want from Liz trust is
complete honesty and transparency during
her time in office yeah I agree with
Lily on later honesty and stuff so if we
can't trust someone that hide then it
won't break out that much I would
personally like to see how she deals
with the cost of living crisis as it is
affecting many people and a lot of
people are struggling my parents are
considering instead of using electricity
just buying a couple of light up candles
electric ones and putting them around
the house so that we don't have to waste
electricity throughout the winter my mom
has a mobile hairdresser so she's using
her car all the time and I feel like the
gas prices and petrol prices have went
up it's like really hard that she's
needing to get from one side of the town
to the other I think one thing that I
hope the Prime Minister does improve
upon is school uniforms and how they
need to lower prices on that because
families are struggling to afford
uniforms here and the cost to get my
uniform and stationaries around 300 to
400 pounds
yeah it's ridiculously expensive I agree
more does need to be done there so thank
you so much for your time guys and
thanks for joining me so as we know the
Prime Minister has a lot to do so Maya
back to you in the studio from Downey
Street thanks Braden nice work
so of course another issue we hope Liz
trust will be dealing with is climate
change
[Music]
coming up an exclusive report from
experts who have dived deep into
unexplored ocean to see how climate
change is affecting marine life
foreign
so while some of us may have been really
excited to get back to school some of
you may have had knots in your stomach
let's face it starting a new school or a
new year group is daunting enough but
there's still a huge amount of us being
bullied too it's just not on
in a moment we'll investigate what to do
if you're being bullied but first check
out this new survey that reveals the
long-term effects of bullying
the Diana award anti-bullying campaign
questioned more than a thousand families
73 of parents said that they were
bullied at school which left them with
low confidence when they became adults
no wonder then that 58 of parents are
worried about us being bullied as we go
back to school
64 of children said that they've
experienced bullying in school and many
say that they have changed their
physical appearance and pretended to be
something they're not in order to fit in
at school
so what do you do if you're bullied well
I got a hold of tomorrow in Manchester
as she was bullied at school but she got
through it and she's now an ambassador
for the Diana award anti-bullying
campaign hey Tamar so
um I understand that you're bullied at
school but what actually happened I
understand you're comfortable sharing it
I was locked upon differently by others
well really it was a particular group of
people and at first I thought all these
people were my friends because we'd hung
out together we'd sit together I was on
free School meals and often they'd make
jokes about that and then it went from
jokes to me being the one that was kind
of left out I said like hey like what's
the problem why can't we just hang out
normally and they said and I called once
you change the color of your skin then
we'll take you seriously wow I'm I'm
really sorry you had to experience that
but how did you get through the building
in the end I mean it seems pretty tough
for a while I kept it to myself but
after that comment so I spoke to one of
the teachers unattrusted adult
um and because they got into trouble for
it I also talked to the rest of the
group also because yes there was one
person that was being the main leader
and the perpetrator and saying these
comments however that didn't erase the
fact that
that people that I also consider my
friends would not saying anything now I
have better friends people that accept
me for who I am and I'm glad that I made
that first step yeah I'm glad that you
didn't stay friends with those people
they sound horrible
um but what advice would you give to
anybody who's being bullied or has been
bullied they only have as much power
over you as you would let them take the
first step of speaking to someone if
anything it can be almost like an
empowering thing because yes when I
stood up for myself I wasn't just
standing up for me in a way I felt like
I was doing something for all the people
that were treated the same way thank you
that's really good advice and thank you
for your time I'm so sorry you had to go
through all of that
victims of bullying shared their stories
and advice in an episode of conversation
this is the series from sky kids FYI
that gives people our age the chance to
have a big conversation about the issues
that affects us they even think that I
belonged in this country as such so they
would just say go back home to where you
belong
you should check it out on Sky Kids On
Demand or head to our webpage
bursts.news FYI and click on the
conversation link
[Music]
Rising temperatures means ice caps are
melting and making sea levels rise
the islands of the Maldives will be the
first in line to disappear Beneath the
Sea and it's not just bad news for
humans
marine life and coral reefs are also in
danger from warmer Waters but did you
know eighty percent of our oceans have
never been explored so for the first
time ever an international group of
scientists are exploring the Indian
Ocean around the Maldives from the
surface to one thousand feet below
they're on a mission to find out how
climate change is affecting marine life
and perhaps even adapting to survive
using submarines and robots the
scientists are heading into unexplored
areas of the Indian Ocean so stand by
for never seen before ocean we ask the
group of scientists to send FYI video
diaries of their expeditions so far
we've been given permission
[Music]
how quickly the flu changes
lots of different types of life
the most obvious are our soft pearls
where we are in the Maldives we're
surrounded by atolls that goes all the
way down to a sea floor
[Music]
in the shallower areas there were lots
of corals growing
and as we've come down here to 120
meters there's this beautiful wall that
we can see and there's lots of different
species
living in these little caverns and caves
Corals in general are really important
areas as habitat for different types of
species of fish and invertebrates
these surveys are really important as
they capture what lives at these
different depths
foreign
[Music]
well the Expedition continues and after
a long day of diving in the Maldives
Lucy and Sheena join me now hi guys hi
so Lucy first off what's the main aim of
the Expedition so on our Expedition
we're trying to try and find out what
lives down to about a thousand meters
and why do they live there would you say
that your Expedition has produced any
worrying results so we like to say that
it takes a long time
to actually really get to the Crux of
what is going on in our ocean and there
isn't a lot known about the deep sea
which is why uh We've undertaken this
Mission together with the government of
Maldives so I like to think that it's
about us appreciating all of the amazing
things that it does for us yeah um and
renewing our attachment to our ocean and
our planet so that we can start
respecting it and being better stewards
of our ocean well keep us updated and
thank you so much for your video diary
guys bye thank you
and the next and team are offering live
lessons from the deep ocean for schools
so get your teacher to check it out
that's about it from FYI today but
remember we won your stories too
[Music]
you can have your say or even report on
a story you want to get out there right
here on FYI we are always after your
views and Story the best way to do that
is to get a teacher to set up an FYI
News Club at your school all members
have the chance to report for us for
details of how you can set up an FYI
News Club at your school and report for
FYI head to our webpage
first.news.fyr that's it for this week
see you next time for more info
[Music]
foreign